good afternoon I'm thrilled to be here
and I'm happy to all of you have come to
hear me talk about the saga pattern I'm
going to introduce the saga pattern by
talking about what motivated me to start
looking into it learning about it give
you a brief history of the saga pattern
although I'm no expert on it and talk
about how to use the saga pattern to
help you deal with undoing side-effects
and asynchronous computations so
starting with a little bit about me I am
a developer outpaced systems this little
graphic was made by one of my co-workers
yesterday just just for us I've been
developing for about 20 years or so now
I have I really enjoy priming a lot I've
been doing a lot of functional / having
these pesto I know five six years and
I've been doing a lot of Scala Clojure
and C++ so this story begins for me
about at the end of last year I was
doing a contract at Monsanto and we were
creating a micro services to help
developers create micro services and and
there's some good things that came out
of this for example there's a an open
source library that we started working
on to give you a nice idiomatic Scala
API for two AWS so if if you're you're
using AWS and using Scala you know
please check it out but getting back to
micro sources creating micro services as
a result of you know what is that we're
trying to do we're interacting with AWS
we have a lot of sequential operations
no we have an operation that we need to
do wait for its return then we do
something else wait for it return and
sometimes you know everything works
great sometimes it doesn't so to give
you kind of a small example of what this
might look like is Irena create an
encryption key
using AWS kms and we want to do a key
pair with an alias because when you
create a key and you get the metadata
back the only way that you can identify
it is through a UUID and this is a
really hostile way to know about what
keys you have so you can create an alias
it gives you a less hostile way of
knowing about them and everything works
great you get a 200 and wallah you have
a key with an alias on AWS and this code
could look like a little bit like this
you have a function that will create the
key it's asynchronous or returns a
future that has a made of data that
comes back from AWS you have another
function that you give it the key ID and
the alias and because Aetherius isn't
give us anything we don't really return
anything either and if you're familiar
with with with Scala there we can
compose these two features together very
easily using this for comprehension so
what this is doing is saying okay go
create this key and when it comes back
you know we're going to put that value
in key and then we're going to go and
create the alias using the value that
we've realized and we don't really care
about the return value here because it's
it's nothing anyway and finally we can
yield you know we can put our Keene
aliens together and hand that back to
the person it invoked us and it's pretty
concise it's very nice but what happens
when things go wrong I mean if create
key goes wrong well it blows up so we
never get a key so we never try to
create an alias so we never return
anything I mean it's not ideal but it
happens but you know no big loss however
what if the second operation fails you
know create alias fails so it doesn't
return successfully we don't return the
sex vessel value but what about that key
that's sitting out on KMS i mean it's
now orphaned we don't know about it
because we don't have that that key
context we don't
we never got that UID in our application
it's just sitting out there and we have
to wait for someone to manually go in
and clean those up once they get the
email from Amazon telling them they
can't create anymore keys so
fundamentally the problem that we have
is that we have a sequential operation
you know operation one the operation two
depends on everyone and in ideal world
they all work just fine but sometimes
they fail and in the first case if it
fails no big deal but in the second case
there's something we want to do in the
case of it fails we want to be able to
delete the key and ideally we want to we
want to codify this whole graph this
whole operation that well if create
Ilyas fails we want to delete the key
and so how do we do that I mean we can
do that there's there's nothing keeps us
from doing that for example if in
addition to creating a create a Lea
staff
delete key well now we can you know
create a create key that can handle this
so now because we're doing something a
little bit different we can't use that
nice for sugar so we create Kiwi flat
map onto it we get the key use that to
create the alias and then we map the key
with the alias up until now this code
right here is exactly what that for
construct was doing at the very
beginning but this is what like expands
out to but now we're going to do
something extra in this case we know
that you know the crate key succeeded
but the recovery or the create a leus
did not and so now we can actually
recover if there was an exception thrown
that's far in in our futures we can you
know get that key or get that exception
you know delete the key and finally you
know can report to the function that
invoked us or the application that
invoked us you know it failed but at
least this time we clean up after
ourselves and so I mean obviously we you
know you can program this and this is a
simple two-step operation but you know
what if it's you know three steps or
four steps or even more I mean we were
certainly dealing with a lot more
just for simple operations and so this
is and this is something that doesn't
really scale I mean it's not specific to
being asynchronous I mean this happens
if you're doing completely synchronous
stuff as well you know to really handle
all these resource leaks you have to do
like nested try catch finally and your
code gets really really nasty after a
while and if you're dealing in the in
the language that kind of gives you
macros I can handle this or if you're
using I guess like closeable to somehow
manage these sorts of things maybe you
might be able to to make things more
pleasant to use but the fundamental
problem is that our concurrency
frameworks don't have this functionality
built in they gave you the tools to
build to build it but it's not easy to
do and it's you you know you might make
an error you might forget to undo an
operation so is there a way that we can
create a library that can handle all of
this safely and and the pattern that we
see here is essentially is that we have
these couplings that you know there's an
action and there's a reversing action so
what if instead of having a graph that
looks like this where we have you know I
haven't counted how many ways that you
can go through that graph but what if we
could make it look something more like
this where each node in the graph knows
that if something fails further on down
the line I know how to clean up after
myself so you know can we do this and so
this is a problem that we we came across
you know last November last December
I've been thinking about it and earlier
in the year I was talking to the former
coworker at a conference and he
suggested that I watched this video of a
talk I think I'd go to Kampf last year
by Carrie McAfee I hope out of that name
right Katy Katy McAfee thank you she had
talked about using the saga pattern
Microsoft
there are she works on video games she
worked with Halo and and they had a
distributed system where you know
players after playing a game send up
their statistics and they have to be
stored and persisted up there and things
sometimes fail this is in and and so he
suggested I that I look into this and so
I did so 30 years ago 1987 about 30
years ago this paper was published out
of Princeton University that talked
about long lived transactions and the
problem here is that you would have
transactions that take a very long time
to complete either because they simply
were doing a lot of work or maybe
they're waiting on input from other
systems or from users and because these
are transactions any database I mean
they're holding on to locks onto
resources which means that anything that
it was locked you know it had its hands
on and says this is mine you can't have
it anyone else who tries to come in and
try to do some work it would say no it's
mine you can't have it go away
and this was causing a performance
problem you know your and the proposed
solution to this it's like well okay
these transactions maybe they don't
really have to be transactional maybe we
can break them up you know if we want to
give away give up some of the guarantees
of having a long-lived database
transaction and we can bundle it up into
smaller packages that each one of these
is a database transaction each one of
these is completely transactional and
has all the asset properties and all
that but between them other things can
happen so we're definitely lose you know
isolation here but we still want to like
retain atomicity of some sort and so
they propose that for each one of these
transactions there's some sort of
compensating transaction so if something
fails you know we can kind of somehow
compensate for that which doesn't
necessarily mean reversing the thing
because maybe you did something that's
irreversible but maybe you can do
something send an apology sorry I didn't
really mean to do this so the guarantee
for atomicity here is that either all
these things will succeed or if there's
a partial success you know all the
things that had succeeded will have
their compensations run so this is a way
of of trying to have some level of
atomicity with that relying on the
database to support it although they did
suggest that the database should support
sagas but in case your database system
doesn't support sagas you know they gave
you some instructions on how you can
implement this using a separate process
so how many of these how many of you
have seen like begin saga in your
favorite database well I'm not sure that
this idea ever really took off again I'm
not an expert on this but someone
someone can correct me if I'm wrong but
the idea didn't die about 15 years ago
you know we're getting to to an age of
you know service-oriented Marc
architectures and micro services and now
we have all sorts of fun distributed
systems and we want transactions but
those don't really work well in a
distributed transaction the more complex
you get the even more complex it becomes
and so the question then becomes well
how can we get some sort of transaction
likeness without actually doing like
two-phase commits and so the saga
pattern was it was was kind of
rediscovered and re-implemented not as a
performance enhancement but as a way of
dealing with errors with recovering from
oops systems that can fail and and I
think it's seen some success of this
there's there's different talks out
there the ones I have mentioned earlier
there's also one that like Ronald Koon I
think that's the name I think he's one
of the akka people
doing he's giving been giving a talk on
like reactive design patterns and the
target patterns one of those they're
he's is a persistent actor to implement
a saga so I'm interested in doing a
synchronous August so I'm mostly
interested in like okay I have some
concurrency constructs in the language
or library that I like to use but I want
to add some undo semantics in there so
I'm not interested in persistence so if
my machine fails if you know if my
program fails or whatever I'm not going
to try to like restore state from some
sort of persistent storm that's not the
problem that I'm trying to solve also
what I'm dealing with doesn't
necessarily have to be distributed it
you know it doesn't need to be in my
case I guess it technically was but I
didn't think of it that way so I'm gonna
talk a little bit about how to do this
using abstractly streams so I did this
using acha streams but theoretically
this could work like quarry sink or go
routines or something else like that so
the primitives that we want to work with
are we have our forward operation this
is the thing that we want to do we get
an input and something happens and we
get an output now we also want to have
the rollback so what if we need to roll
back that operation at some point later
on well we have a robotic operation so
that one takes the IMP input the output
that was generated by our forward
routine and we really don't care about
the result of this and we're just
executing this for side-effects
we love side-effects so how do you
compose these two things together two to
create like 101 of these things that
knows about the forward and the reverse
I mean you can't just put them together
because you need to have some way of
collect coordinating both the forward
and the reverse side and so the way I
went about this is to have the forward
taken
try which is a algebraic data type that
I can you know have it success with a
value or failure with an exception and
so you're going to be getting inputs
that either you know valid inputs or
exceptions and you're going to output
the same on the other way around
you're going to essentially either going
to get an exception or not and the way
this one is going to work in practice is
that if you have a success then you'll
do your operation and if you're
successful you'll pass it down
eventually if everything that's
depending on you works just fine you're
going to get a none and that means you
don't have to do anything you can just
pass it back so that's great well what
happens when the world isn't happy which
is happens way too often well if we have
an exception that comes from downstream
we know that well we have to invoke our
undo operation and then once we finished
we can pass this exception you know back
to anyone who we might be depending on
well what if we fail well if we fail we
have our exception that we've kind of
passed forward and eventually comes back
to us and we just pass it back what if
upstream had failed well that means
we're going to get a failure and we just
pass it around it's pretty simple so how
do we do this well we just have to do a
little bit of wrapping of our forward to
handle the case of well first we have
our try now in our try if it's a
successful that we're going to run this
other kind of little graph that's going
to run our forward operation if it's
successful it's going to wrap that
successful return value in a success but
in the case it wasn't then we're going
to recover it we're gonna get that
exception you know package it in a
failure and pass it down and the case
that we had a failure to begin with we
repackage the failure so that it has a
say you know the correct type and we
pass it down to do the roll back flow it
looks very similar in this case we have
both
the output from our forward operation in
this tryout and the exception that came
from downstream the and we we have this
just as a single argument as a tuple so
in the case that we were successful but
upstream or downstream was unsuccessful
then we perform a rollback operation and
kind of discard the result and get that
exception back and we pass it down and
any other case so if we succeeded then
upstream will either have you know will
have succeeded or if he failed then
upstream will have failed and then
there's nothing for us to do we passed
the exception back and you know that's
about it now we have the basic building
blocks that we need to put together our
our stage so the only thing that we're
adding here is essentially that
coordination mechanism between the
upstream and the downstream so we have
our input that comes in we run it
through a wrapped forward that's either
going to return this guy returns some
sort of try and we're gonna broadcast it
so broadcast just means is all we're
gonna take that input value and make two
copies of it and send it in two
different directions and we're using
this as a synchronization mechanism so
one one copy is gonna go downstream
didn't anyone who depends on us and the
other one's going to come in to this zip
function which is essentially just a
reverse so it's gonna collect two values
and produce one that contains the two of
them and so finally when we do get that
input we'll send it to our roll back
functionality which you know may or may
not do something depending on what these
values are and finally we can return our
our our output or throwable and you know
this kind of gives us that building
block that we're looking for now you can
essentially just stack one block on top
of the other so long as you know the
types match up because we're using Scala
and we have types but there's still one
thing left here I mean what we have is
essentially like this big pipe but it's
got a big leak on the on one side and we
have our inputs but any inputs
it's gonna fall off the other side so we
need to cap this pipe and the way we do
this is essentially by doing something
similar to what we were doing in in our
individual stage but now we do it for
the whole flow so here this the stage
that we have at the a and a prime I mean
it could be just one operation it could
be a hundred operations but from our
standpoint it looks the same so the
first thing I do is to get our raw input
we have to wrap it in a success because
that's what our stages expect and we
execute eventually we're going to get
some sort of value out of that so it
could be a successful value it could be
an unsuccessful value and what we're
going to do is work out again we're
going to use this broadcast and zip
pattern to synchronize between like the
output of the forward in the output of
the of the reverse so in the case that
it was a success then we know that this
operation succeeded and we can pass none
down so that everyone else can just say
okay I'm good and the case is a failure
then we pass the exception back down and
everyone can either just pass it along
or do the roll back depending other on
their individual state once so that's
what happened to finally once that roll
back operation completes now we have our
two or two things synchronizing together
in zip with and we're using a zip with
here instead of zip because essentially
we don't really care about the result
from the roll backs we're just going to
use the result from the forward
operation and return that and here I did
to choose a returning a try with the
output because since this is a stream
this allows us to do indefinite number
of values you can just send in values
all day and they'll either succeed or
fail
and whereas but if you wanted to change
this so that you only get a single value
that either you know throws an exception
or drops bad values that's trivial to
add on after this so there's so this is
very basic and it doesn't really cover
like all the
the Saugus paper talks about you know
they talk about well forward recovery
what if you have save points so that say
t3 has a safe point attached so that
when it succeeds anything that feels
after that it can restart from that
point and I don't have that coded into
into you know the prototype in the
library that I'm working on but there
were two glad something that should be
possible much more exciting to me I
think is paralyzation you know what if
you can have a complex graph where
you're doing all sorts of operations
some of them in parallel but you can
still have them all clean up after
themselves I think that's possible but I
haven't gone around to trying it yet but
it's not just for streams I I have done
like a little prototype with a future
that is like a saga future and and it
works but I think it's a little bit
harder to work with because of a few
kind of constraints the cipher so the
futures are really nice because they are
you know they it's it represents a
computation so it's like a monad over
like a future computed value but to do a
saga future as a monad now it's of a
tuple of also your computation and the
roll back that you might need to evoke
in the future so that makes a little bit
harder to implement but and it also
makes it harder to make and the really
nice clean API for it but one of the big
problems I that I think there is with
futures it's up because they don't live
in an environment that has like that
saga execution manager or context
they're unaware of what context that
they're running one so someone manages
to reach in you know pierce your saga
feature and grab you know the feature
inside they can be referencing and use
it but it's possible that after they get
that value you know that a rollback
operation might have undone whatever
that value had done to it so that's a
problem and how do you create a present
API with this so it's only possible and
I'll probably get around to it at some
point but
don't let the fact that I did streams
keep you from doing anything else also
in the case of akka streams it's trivial
to put a future in the stream so as a
good mathematician with future as we
just reduce it to a problem has already
been solved so let's now that we've
talked about this you know what does
this look like in practice you know
let's go back to our original scenario
and so I've created here a number of
flows to represent like the simple
operations the primitives that we want
to use we can build these using the
functions or the function signatures I
showed you earlier I'm not going to do
that here just because of you know time
but the one difference that we're gonna
see here is that because of the linear
nature of this like any input that's
needed further downstream needs it
passed in from the front so our key
creator takes an alias as an argument
even though it doesn't use it and it
just passes it down to the next stage so
it's input here's a string and then
outputs a string a tuple of the string
and the key metadata the deleter of
course has to take that tuple as its
argument even though it only uses the
key metadata or alias Creator you know
it takes those inputs it Maps nicely and
now because we've attacked you know as a
result of this operation the alias is
now part of the key metadata we no
longer need to return that string
anymore we've consumed it so that's not
part of our types of nature and because
we're doing sagas and we have to have
both the forward and reverse operations
I have an alias deleter
so in my library
creating a saga flow is a lot if you're
familiar like my streams there's like
bi-directional flow so you can create
just from two flows well saga flows
works pretty much the same way you just
give it the ford flow and the reverse
flow and it gives you essentially your
your little stage we do that with both
key and the alias and finally we can
create our master flow that's going to
do everything and clean up after itself
and its really simple to build we take
our stage that builds the key we stack
the stage that does a alias on top of it
and then we convert it to the flow that
we want and we could add all sorts of
other operations to this if we are so
inclined and so at this point it's just
a matter we have as you know in this
case as an extreme thing we have
essentially a representation of our
computation that involves the rollbacks
that we can pass around and instantiate
whenever we will so my conclusions from
kind of looking into this is that sorry
guys I think are a very useful way of
thinking about error recovery and how
you're going to do that I mean when you
have a complex process now how can we
break it down into simpler steps that we
can then manage and most importantly I
think for me is that I can create
libraries that will implement this so
that later so that gives me kind of
better concurrency building blocks I can
build more robust reliable systems with
less work because I already spent a lot
of time thinking about it upfront and
created a library I can reuse and it's
something that other people can reuse
but not quiet I mean it I have some work
out there it's still very raw I need to
but eventually I will release a library
and put it up on bin tray or something
so that's it thank you very much I
appreciate your time